men have always tried to encode secrets
military communication love letters
forbidden knowledge sooner or later
most secret texts have been decoded
but among all of history's cryptic
writings one has stood out 13 o clock
hey there it's Tuesday and that means
it's time for the latest installment of
13 o'clock this would be episode 110
god damn damn they'd just pile up they
do we've just been doing 110 weeks of
this [ __ ] man yeah and actually you know
it's it's and it's more well and it's
more shows than that because we started
doing well I'm just saying is 110 weeks
of it yeah true yeah that's true but
actually I had the idea to do this now
I've had this topic kind of it's kind of
been shuffled around on the topic list
for the last few years but you know the
last couple months but because we just
did the last show about the zodiac and
the stuff about the ciphers and
everything like that I had been wanting
to do a show about like some creepy or
like mysterious codes or you know cases
that involve codes and I've also wanted
been talk to talk about the Voynich
managing yeah so I decided that on this
show we're gonna do kind of a mysterious
codes thing and Jenny dug out some new
stuff about the voyage made well it's
recent and it's like I don't even think
it's on the Wikipedia page yet I'm not
sure how so it's almost like an
exclusive yeah like I'm not sure how
accurate it is you know what I mean I'm
not about them yeah I'm not a linguist
so I'm you know I'm not saying but it
does kind of look like maybe they're
onto something but we'll see how that
goes so what we're gonna do is we're
probably gonna do like in lieu of a news
story since we're doing three cases
we'll probably just do the three cases
instead of doing a news story because I
want to do
Ricky mcCormick I want to do the
so-called Yangtze or a Yangtze fall case
and then we'll talk about the the
Voynich manuscript probably like on the
second part of the show after the break
that's what I'm shooting for anyway
we'll see how it goes like I said I
don't I don't script these really I have
notes in kind of a general direction but
then I just kind of let it go however
yeah well before we do that let's do our
regular shout outs as I mentioned before
the faceless villain vol 2
the print version and the eBook version
are both available for sale on Amazon
yeah already selling too and yes and
some people have are I have bought some
copies so if you're among those people
thank you very much I would appreciate
it if you could write a short review if
you like the book that really does help
a lot and I've been slowly recording the
audio version I've got several of the
chapters done it's like I can pretty
much only do like two three chapters a
day before my voice starts getting
shredded because the chapters are very
long so you know it'll probably be a few
more weeks before I get it finished and
uploaded and everything because I still
have to edit all of it yeah this is
gonna be the best audio quality that
we've produced so far so far yeah and
like I said you know eventually I'm
gonna go back and rerecord some of the
other audio books like on scene hand and
stuff and I'm also gonna start working
on doing new editions of my fiction
which has so far never been an audio
book format so I'm redesigning covers
I'm reformatting like some of my fiction
books and I'm then I'm gonna release
audio book versions yeah compilations
most of them yeah most of all be it'll
it'll be like it'll either be all short
stories or it'll be like a short novel
with you know some short stories at the
end or two short novels and one button
guys gonna like her short stories it
kind of reminds me of Clive Barker type
stuff good yeah I mean he's one of my
main inspiration yes him and Edgar Allen
Poe and that's perverse range birdie and
gross yeah some of our not yet now some
of them are Emily gross well some of it
might be Congress just weird you guys
are gonna like it I have a weird
imagination yeah there would have been
good like you know in movies yeah I do
open someone's gonna someone's gonna
make so much [ __ ] in a movie so well
because that's when I when I write it
that's how I picture it I picture it as
though it's a movie in my brain and I'm
describing it yes that's how I do it um
speaking of movies if you didn't see our
last movie review was Creepshow and i
had been so so excited about doing that
because i love that movie so much that's
one of my favorite movies of the 80s
easily my favorite horror anthology
you know so go check that out if you
haven't already let's see what else all
like I usually say if you want to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page obviously which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast I'd
also like to give a shout out to our
patron Michael who increased his support
and we also have a new patron this week
named
fiki thank you and thank you awesome
Michael for upping your support um like
I said we also have Tom shitty movies
Facebook group which is which is going
fun he's been posting some cool videos
yeah a bunch people trying to get in not
everybody got in well it's kind of deal
where if I really couldn't check your
social media you know what I mean if I
couldn't really figure out who you were
they'd enough probably not not safe to
really let you in or if I saw something
you know social media maybe you were
acting bad you didn't get in not only
wanting troublemakers yeah it's gotta be
the bouncer yeah got to be kind of the
bouncer now one one that you posted that
was not a shitty movie actually we went
because my birthday is coming up yet is
that it's actually the day after this
episode comes out September 26 and I had
been wanting to see I know it's a kids
movie all I had been wanting to see the
house of the clock and its walls because
you guys this was my favorite book when
I was a kid look check it if you're
watching on the video look at here I got
this at Barnes & Noble a few years ago
I'm so excited this is actually the
whole trilogy house the clock in so
let's figure in the shadows and the
letter the witch in the ring and I've
reread it several times at his adult I
still love it I love this book forever
it has Edward Gorey illustrations and
it's funny because a couple of years ago
when there was you know the big thing
with Harry Potter and Allison that was
like a huge success in the movies were
see huge success
I was like why the [ __ ] is nobody ever
made house with a clock and it's walls
into a movie it's like I've been wanting
them to make a movie out of it since the
80s like the only I think the only
adaptation of it was it was on like a
little an thought like a TV Halloween
anthology called Once Upon a midnight
gary i think it was called and it was
Vincent prices in it and it was only
like a 40-something minute segment and
it was really not good it was like from
the 70s or something and because the
book came out in 1973 but I was like man
they really need especially in light of
Harry Potter and all the y-a stuff that
got super famous I'm like why isn't
anybody it's an amazing amazing story
and finally someone did yeah so I told
Tom I'm like for an early birthday
present you're gonna take me to see it I
know it's a kid's movie and I don't
usually like that kind of [ __ ] I don't
know you're probably gonna hate it but I
really really want to see it and I
really hope they don't [ __ ] it up
because I love this book so much and but
I you know I went into it with
trepidation because I was like I really
hope they don't mess it I didn't even
know until we went there that Eli Roth
torture porn king he did hostel and the
green inferno and stuff that he actually
directed it so I was like what they
actually that kind of made me feel
better so I was like oh it's a horror
director so that's good it was a good
movie it was like way way way better
it's young adult adults would enjoy it's
scary and yet there's enough action and
adventure there to at least kind of draw
an adult in you know go with lo hey I
like the villain the villain actually
kind of had it was kind of he's kind of
a respectable villain and Tom McLaughlin
it was coming yeah and they even give
gave him a backstory so you know who it
is you're dealing with it was a good it
was a good story one thing I liked about
it is it's almost like a throwback so
I'm watching Grimm that's what I was
gonna say it had a very Spielberg E and
80s like a throwback when when they were
when they would make like
family-friendly movies but that were
scary right you know like gremlins or
The Goonies or Indiana Jones at the time
or you know something like that that had
really scared like oh I'm gonna tear
their heart out but it's you know fun
for the whole family but it's kind of
like that I was actually surprised
because I thought I was like oh they
better not make it all cutesy and fun
and everything like it had like some
little like toilet humor type stuff but
it was they said it um
at around the time actually the book was
set in 1948 the movie set in 1955 but
the you know close enough and they
actually I was afraid they would make it
not as scary as the book it did but I
was like wow a lot of times they went
there like some of it is pretty scary
and you know the kid is actually in
mortal danger as are many of
other people like people are in danger
getting killed and stuff like that so
don't shy away from anything and like I
said I mean when we saw it you said that
little kid that was sitting next to you
see I like that I think they should be
outside I was like yeah I got it they
should make more kid movies that are
scary like I will never that move my
keys and what's funny got quiet yeah
yeah the little kids watched it they
just you know yeah they were like there
were little kids in the audience they
shut the [ __ ] up quick a bunch of people
brought me a little little bit they're
like oh [ __ ] I was like that when I saw
Star Wars their very first one new hope
I did I was just glued to it yeah that's
all the kids were just glued to it I
guess that some of the adults do it was
a good movie what I liked about it is it
was solid storytelling they didn't
insert any [ __ ] or ulterior motives
or and there wasn't any contemporary
politics in it
Ernie crapped like that it just stuck to
the source material they didn't subvert
it and try to try to do something else
with it it just it was the story yeah it
like to modernize it they made a couple
of changes from the book but nothing
super major and honestly the changes
that they made I think were good ones
because you know like I said some things
that work in a book don't work in a
movie as well they kind of made the the
climax like more exciting yeah I kind of
thought you know it reminded me a lot of
other movies or one of the movies that
kind of reminded me of in terms of kind
of like magnitude would have been that
new first episode of it it one yeah I'm
like that was hard or is an adult
yeah wasn't quite easy it wasn't as gory
it was just as cool as that yeah if you
like to have move you'd like this one
like this one if you'd like you know
[ __ ] like Dark Crystal they stole the
poltergeist one yeah it'd be like saying
it has that kind of vibe it's like a big
80s family-friendly movie that still has
like scary parts yeah the whole family
could enjoy and it's very gothic like I
as soon as I saw this set very good act
like wall of the house I was just like
oh man that was just like I imagined it
so I was
thrilled about it I was gonna be
indifferent and then I was like when I
got when it got done I was like I want
to see the second one yeah because I'm
kind of hoping I mean they set up at the
end you know if you if you've read the
book they set up at the end where he
meets Rosarita Pottenger who is a
character in the subsequent two
installments so I'm assuming that if it
does well that they'll make the whole
trilogy which would be really neat
because I don't know why they don't make
more John Bell it's a simple premise
young kid and what was funny is that
there's kids in the movie but they're
not candies if you know what a candy is
the kid the kids that are in it the
characters that are rated they're good
yeah Jack Black's awesome Anna who was
the girl who's Blanchett yes it's kind
of simple it's kind of a simple setup
kids parents die he gets sent to his
uncle's house his uncle lives in this
big-ass [ __ ] scary haunted mansion
turns out his uncle's got a secret his
uncle's a sorcerer
yeah his uncle teaches him how to use
sorcery it's it's a pretty cool kind of
like there's a story hero's journey
story arc almost kind of like Luke
Skywalker and obi-wan Kenobi but it's
more comical but in a little you know it
there's a lot of a lot to this actually
Conor was almost kind of like the
original Star Wars trilogy the bad guy
was kind of like a Sith Lord he did look
kind of like yeah sorcerer he was kind
of like using the force you know there
was you know kind of like that yeah but
it's but it was definitely definitely a
fun movie and like I said if you miss
the old days of like scary kid oriented
movies then this is really a breath of
fresh air and I'm kind of hoping that
it's you know a harbinger of what's to
go they're gonna start doing that more
that like they're gonna have kids movies
that are actually scary like a lot of
the ones were yeah it's not like a
modern movie it's yeah it's really not
it's like a throwback and like I said
I'm so glad that they set it back at the
time period that the book was originally
I mean because I was like please do not
set it in the modern day with like cell
phones and not as ironic slang and [ __ ]
like yeah not as not as cynical as say
Creepshow one but in that same vein yeah
it was
just a fun it's a fun good-looking movie
and you know it's just a cool story some
give very gothic looking except not like
in a Tim Burton a way but you know like
an old-school Victorian kind of look but
yeah I really really better than a good
Tim Burton movie actually yeah it wasn't
as affected
I guess mannered cool just some of his
but it was but and I saw that first but
we're going on and on about this man
that's it was really good though it's
all good I saw that first Harry Potter
movie it was okay but this was a lot
better yeah the Harry Potter movies like
I said they got better that's the Kamiya
this one was kind of like kind of like
that scarier kind of like the new it it
would yeah like I said didn't have a
similar vibe yeah except I wouldn't take
a kid a little kid just go see it no
that's a little much right but it was
this one you could probably good this
one I wouldn't take like a baby like a
toddler but if they're like six and up
well they'd love that [ __ ] they probably
cuz I mean I liked seeing scary movies
in those little I would you know what I
mean well snowbird told the guy to make
it scary that the kids loved it yeah
that's what I don't forget it
Eli Roth said that Steve we burn our
audience no make it scary our audience
our regular audience knows when we were
kids they just get shadows we love it we
were all those movies I remember all
this movies very fondly and that's what
made me want to be a horror writer yeah
cuz I loved being scared and I mean I
watched slasher movies too when I was
probably two yeah but you know whatever
my parents were right 13:1 yeah we're
back and watch part of the 13th one hand
two and those movies weren't even gory I
know I remembered them being so gory and
their 13th one other than our head
popping off it's like it's not real or
dead gory they kind of cut away yeah
before I thought that was kind of weird
but like I said it's kind of like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre where you remember it
as being much gory or than Davian they
usually like cut away before they didn't
show like anyone's entrails like fallen
out or anything like that like they tune
happenings but yeah so I think that's
probably all the shoutouts so let's like
I said we're not gonna do a news story
because we have so many other you know
so many cases that we want to get into I
think the first one let's talk about the
Ricky McCormick case first yeah I don't
know anything about okay
this is pretty pretty weird all right
this happened in 1999 in Missouri
now it's June 30th and they find the
body of this 41 year old man Ricky
McCormick Ricky McCormick they find him
in a cornfield where they find him is
about 15 20 miles from his house which
they think is a little weird because he
doesn't drive he doesn't have a car you
know there's no sanitation
no no it was far away it was just like
way out in the middle of nowhere type
thing so the last time that he was seen
was three days before his death and
apparently he was seen at the Amoco gas
station where he worked he had also been
at a hospital emergency room he had
actually they found out in the days
prior to his death he had actually gone
to the emergency room a couple of times
the first time was four he had he said
that he had been complaining of chest
pains and shortness of breath now it
should be noted that Ricky mcCormick
since childhood he had had really bad
asthma he also had a heart condition
unspecified heart condition but it was a
bad enough heart condition that he was
actually on disability and had been for
for a very long time so so he apparently
stayed at this stay at the hospital
overnight then they let him go and then
either the day before he was last seen
or the day of he went to the hospital
and he was complaining again a shortness
of breath now they didn't admit him they
just said it was a really bad asthma
attack I guess presumably they gave him
some medication or whatever and then
they sent him home but then they said
that he actually stayed in the waiting
room like and slept there overnight like
he didn't want to go home or something
like that
he thought it would come back maybe or
you know some people have posited some
other things okay so here's the strange
thing they find the guy's body now he
had been there for three days because he
had been seen alive you know three days
before they found him
but his body was so decomposed that they
could not determine cause of death must
have been summer summer it was it was
June it was very rough yeah um but they
said what that was a little unusual that
he was that decomposed after only three
days no but he but they saw him like he
was seen a couple places on the 27th
okay um so at first now from what I've
seen of the news stories from 1999 when
the body was found at first they didn't
necessarily think it was a homicide okay
because they couldn't determine a cause
of death they're like well he had a lot
of health issues you know he had the
heart condition he had asthma you know
he was a very heavy smoker and so
they're presuming well maybe he was
hitchhiking out somewhere he just died
of natural causes and got dumped out of
a car or who knows or something like
that so then the case kind of stayed but
then weirdly 12 years later the FBI
comes out and are not only announcing
that for sure this is a homicide they're
not saying how they know that now but
they're asking for the public's help in
trying to decipher these two pieces of
paper that were found in Ricky
McCormick's pocket these two pieces of
paper and if you are watching the video
I will show you the piece of paper or
you can see the moment Wikipedia you can
just google and bricky McCormick's
encrypted notes is the Wikipedia page
and they have pictures of them and
they're also on the FBI's website
because the FBI have been working on
decoding this [ __ ] for 12 years best
cryptographers in the world working on
it and they can't [ __ ] figure out
what it says I haven't seen it now what
they are it's just these two sheets of
paper like one of them says notes at the
top like it was pulled from the back of
you know like a day planner or something
like that they're just like these groups
of words they look like and they're like
from the pattern of it it looks like
something that could be decoded like it
looks like something that you know was
done like it you know how they do the
cryptograms like with the substitution
yeah
or you know like a shift with the
letters or something like that they're
like it looks like something like that
because the patterns look like they
could be actual words some of the words
are in parentheses like phrases and
parentheses there's a bunch of ease
which they think might signify a space
so like I said they've been working on
this for 12 years and they're not sure
and they're like well they're you know
they don't know if it has anything to do
with the murder but they want them
decoded because you know in case it does
hold on one second what's that so he was
found dead when what year was this 1999
okay and then 12 years later they opened
up the FBI came forward said we know
this is a homicide yeah and they're not
saying why they know it's a homicide
right well I think and I'll get into it
a little bit later that would - what
dude that's 12 years yeah okay it's 12
years okay but um you know so so wrong
2011 yeah 2011 they came out and you
know they posted a get some kind of a
witness in custody they said well yeah
oldest guys know but what I'll get into
that in a little bit but what I was
gonna say was that the weird thing about
these notes wold one of the weird things
other than they can't figure out what
the [ __ ] it says is that by the accounts
of Ricky McCormick's family he was
illiterate or only semi-literate I
remember this guy his father now his
mother called him quote [ __ ] yeah
wasn't this a black guy yeah okay he was
actually um he made it most of the way
through school he dropped out of high
school I saw yeah and then kind of took
on a bunch of odd jobs like keeper
chooses janitor he works at a gas
station he works places like that um
some his family said he might have
suffered from some kind of mental
illness maybe schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder something like that but
evidently he couldn't write his own name
or that's all he could write yeah like I
said sources differ but mostly his
family said that he was pretty much
illiterate did do they think that that's
his handwriting see they're not sure
because they don't have any other
samples of his rating could it could he
been pretending to
right well there are actual letters but
maybe by his schizophrenia kicked in and
he was aware so he's pretending to rice
so okay so what they're going on and
what they found out later on it's weird
because like the first few the first few
things that I read about this case
actually didn't mention all this other
stuff but then I went back and like dug
deeper down and apparently and this
might be why the FBI now thinks this is
a homicide
two weeks before Ricky McCormick turned
up dead they discovered that he had
bought a one-way bus ticket to Orlando
and they pulled all the phone records
from the time and they said that you
know prior to him going to Orlando he
made a bunch of like short phone calls
to people there and when he was there he
made some phone calls back to his
hometown including to the two brothers
who owned the gas station that he worked
at now according to his girlfriend whose
name is Sandra Jones she said that the
two brothers that owned the gas station
where he worked were like drug runners
and that Ricky McCormick would sometimes
go places and pick up marijuana now it
doesn't say I don't think there was any
drugs harder than marijuana I don't you
know what I mean that's all the only
drug they ever mentioned so I'm assuming
the FBI is presuming that Ricky
McCormick was sent to Orlando to pick up
a shipment of marijuana and then bring
it back but they're not sure if
something that happened in Orlando
because according to his girlfriend he
said when she said when he got back from
Orlando he was acting weird or like
acting scared and that's why some people
have said you know he turned up at the
emergency rooms of these two separate
hospitals and then at the one Hospital
and this was like the day before he died
he actually they released him but then
he spent the night in the waiting room
like he didn't want to leave or I didn't
want to go home like he thought someone
was after him or something like that
some people have speculated he also had
schizophrenia well that's it's not
diagnosed his family member said that it
they thought maybe it was something like
that like he had some kind of mental
mental illness so here's the thing
there's a couple of theories about these
notes that they found on his person yeah
um they're like well okay now it's
possible that whoever killed him wrote
the notes um although why would they
leave them on the body that seems a
little strange but you may have to see
if he was killed right not really sure
it was a homicide just right cuz he was
so decomposed you couldn't tell right
right as far as I know they do not know
cause of death they did do a toxicology
they did do all that kind of stuff no
drugs no alcohol no nothing like that
but like I said now they're treating it
like a homicide so I'm assuming that
there's some other but I don't know if
we know what she was jumping into my
mind
12 years passed and then all of a sudden
they're saying this is a homicide case
that means somebody in connection with
this death got arrested and was in
prison and then he goes look I got a 12
year old homicide I'll testify if you
let me out yeah that's what that's what
he's doing trying to get a cut a deal
and then this guy tells the FBI certain
things that interest them but there's
also another thing that you got to know
about jailhouse snitches sometimes they
try to lie well yeah obviously and
they'll even invent a crime all right
hoping that maybe somebody else will get
charged for it or the investigation will
shift somewhere else and they'll be
freed so there may be a situation where
there's a guy who knew about the death
knew him okay the guy who died and he
makes up a plausible story that to make
it sound like a homicide in hopes of
being released yeah I'm talking about I
mean okay some one thing that should be
noted is that this particular cornfield
yeah is known as something of a criminal
dumping ground okay uh there was a
prostitute I believe was murdered in
1985 and was dumped there and after
Ricky McCormick's death I believed there
were two other murders like later on
where the bodies were dumped there as
well
it starts to sound a little more
plausible right maybe somebody was
killed and like I said how did he end up
so far I mean that was really far from
his house yeah my mom was killed dumped
some kind of organized crime ring he did
that's what I think what most people are
got arrested he no knew about it because
I can tell you what happened that guy he
told him what happened that guy and
they're trying to prove it what the no
code thing that's weird what most people
are thinking is that since the brothers
that owned the gas station were kind of
known to be drug dealers that maybe
Ricky McCormick had been running errands
for them and that he [ __ ] up somehow
or something like that and petition guy
and they either killed him or there's
this other guy named Gregory Knox who
was sort of a hit man he got killed for
it for like bumping off other people he
got done for bumping off other people
and they're trying to establish a link
between the brothers that owned the gas
station and this Gregory Knox person
because Gregory Knox apparently the
rumor went that he's like oh yeah that
guy killed a black man and dumped him in
West Alton Missouri which they think
might be Ricky McCormick so whether so
there's another thing too that they're
thinking that maybe if this whole thing
was have having to do with drug
trafficking that the notes may have been
encoded instructions like for example
maybe it was phone numbers or addresses
or contacts of people who he was
supposed to you know get in touch with
in Orlando like on his trip and they put
it in some kind of like uncrackable code
so that the cops wouldn't know what it
said so that's one possibility could
have been just carrying the code because
you've had smart enough to crack it
himself
right that's what some people have said
that maybe he didn't even write it then
maybe he was just courier yeah you know
here is a courier yeah that he did
someone else had written it and he
didn't even know what it said but that's
why so now and some people have said too
that if Ricky McCormick indeed did write
it which I said I don't know how
possible that is because like I said his
family said that he was illiterate
pretty much so whether he wrote it or
not or maybe it doesn't even mean
anything it does like I said it does
look like it has a pattern
of an actual language and actual words
I'm gonna tell you right but if it's a
code if it is a code he didn't have
anything to do is that he was just
carrying it he was carrying it for the
people that he worked for it was for
whatever client he was there to deal
with that's probably what it was it's
just interesting how they've never been
able to crack it because it's really
it's one of the very very few codes that
the FBI cryptographers have never ever
it was the brac whoever it was meant for
had a key to crack it must be something
like how I did another show about the
yeah we didn't number stations yeah we
didn't want about nobody something like
a number station code yeah where if you
don't know what you don't know what he's
gone with the wind' page 29 if you have
that page you can use that cipher to
crack that code yeah but if you don't
know it you don't know what book to look
in and what page it is then it won't
work some people have also speculated
that maybe since he was mentally ill
like you said this was just like
gibberish or nonsense that he was
writing that doesn't mean anything and
actually when I was watching the brain
scratch episode about this and somebody
in the comment section said that they
actually knew a guy like this homeless
guy in their town that he would talk to
periodically and he said that guy used
to do the same thing like he had this
little book and he would just always be
writing in it and when you looked at it
it looked like it was sort of like tanks
but it didn't mean anything it was just
like a bunch of letters you know what I
mean but they kind of looked like words
but they didn't say in gibberish right
so and the guy was mentally ill and he
said oh I'm just writing down what's in
my head
like he was just seeing letters
investors writing down so it's possible
that Ricky McCormick could have done the
same thing so maybe he did write it but
it doesn't mean anything but at any rate
if anybody thinks that they can get to
the bottom of it
you can go right to the FBI page they
have a page right there where all your
amateur cryptographers can go and take a
crack at it it's pretty weird just the
two pages are very weird like some of
the stuff is circled like said there's
parentheses who knows what the hell it
means if it's a code and not some
gibberish it's gonna be like a number
stations code it's kind of bad they
weren't cracked it already if it wasn't
it has to be something like
it has something like its agreed but
agreed upon between the sender and the
receiver that the code is to unlock the
code you have to know the page number of
a certain book yeah what book it is what
book it is it's gone with the wind' page
147 and if you have that page and you
can combine it with that you can see the
number stations you watch there are
number stations showed it will explain
what I'm talking about yeah
and if those two items together you'll
be able to unlock it but from what I
remember it was just like two short
paragraphs I mean very small paragraph
it's um it's basically it's two sheets
it's like one of them has like three or
four paragraphs on it and then the other
one has a couple paragraphs on it that
are that are sort of like parenthetical
like it's just like a paragraph and then
there's like lines with parentheses
around them it's just it's very odd but
to me it seems more likely that it was
something that his employer or whoever
sent him on the errand yeah maybe wrote
as a message to someone else like to
whoever he was going to pick up the
stuff from and that guy knew what the
key was probably was an order for drugs
it might have been like I said or it
might have been a contact or addresses
or something or you know some itinerary
who knows it might have been something
like that but it does I mean from all
the they know that it's not gibberish in
the sense that it has the pattern of
English like it has the pattern of a
language of things that are actual words
that are encoded because they can tell
that so it probably does say something
secret message but I was asked this
though is it actually the courier to
know what the message because you know
how like on that same show that we did
Somerton man that was like our eerie
espionage show [ __ ] that was like a long
time ago that was like episode four or
something it was like it was one of our
first shows um and remember how we were
saying like the key maybe for that the
Somerton man code was maybe for the
Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam I was wondering
is it better to use a an unusual book or
is it better to use one like the Bible
or one that like everybody's heard of
you know what I mean better to use
it's better to use a common book like
the Bible that's what I was thinking
like it sounds counterintuitive because
you'd think that like Oh we'd never
think of using like some [ __ ] random
textbook from 1957 about yeah vacuum
cleaner to observe you know what I mean
it's just something like that
but maybe because like you said the
Bible or a copy of [ __ ] I mean
nowadays it'd be not all Bibles the same
it had be like King James Bible yeah I
mean it just seems better like to have
the key be something that is common
common enough that people wouldn't
remark upon people having having it
right because flies did it that's yeah
cuz I think is real common wouldn't
wouldn't attract attention yeah it's
like you should have a copy of like Moby
Dick or something like no one's gonna
think that's weird
I've thought of Moby Dick because I was
because I just saw Heather's the other
day
Eskimo actually moby moby dick might
might attract attention today true like
you know I wasn't with Harry Potter now
you want a Harry Potter look yeah John
Grisham earth Stephen King or Twilight
or something like because yeah no one
would think that was weird that you had
it and you could use that's cool let's
like in code all kind of [ __ ] with some
of my Stephen King books and yeah I got
a [ __ ] ton of them but yeah so like I
said if you want to take a crack at it
just go to the FBI website or just
google Ricky McCormick encrypted notes
and you can go check them out and see if
you can figure it out nobody else has
but maybe you'll be the one fingers that
happen no it's not cracking it probably
is I'm thinking at this point if all the
best crypto analysts in the world have a
figured that [ __ ] is off then I don't
think you're gonna be able to I don't
think anyone's gonna go build know be
able to all right so the next case let's
talk about let's see what what we're
like on time okay we're only at 35
minutes okay so this one won't take that
long
to go into now this is a very famous
case on the internet comes up a lot
during these weird unusual deaths that
involve a code it's usually known as the
yangtze case or Yangtze fall it happened
in Germany in 1984 there was this guy
named Gunther Stoll and he was a food
technician although he was unemployed at
the time
this particular incident according to
his wife now he had been having some
paranoia for I'm for some period of time
before that he seemed to think that
people were after him and what else and
so you know they they're after me
they're gonna come get me you know the
eponymous they we're gonna come after
him and stuff like that now on October
25th apparently he was sitting at home
with his wife about 11 p.m. he suddenly
jumps up and says a phrase in German
which I'm not even going to attempt to
pronounce but roughly translated sued
now I have it or now I understand he
goes over to the table and he writes on
the piece of paper y ou G or possibly
six then an apostrophe then a t ze he
writes that on a piece of paper then he
immediately scratches it out then he
leaves his house goes to his favorite
tavern was a favorite little watering
hole he orders a beer
according to other people in the bar he
did not even take one sip of beer before
he falls the [ __ ] off his barstool hits
his head on the floor and goes
unconscious for a couple of seconds or
he went unconscious before he fell like
and then he fell off the person I don't
know but he's falls off the bar so he
was they said he wasn't drunk or
anything he seemed upset but they said
he wasn't any breathing even him drink
his beer so he wakes back up and he's
apparently alright he doesn't finish his
beer he leaves the bar then his
whereabouts are unaccounted for for
about two hours the next time they saw
him he turned up in his childhood
hometown he was knocking on the door of
this elderly woman that he had known
growing up I said I think she was like a
neighbor of his when he was a kid so he
was she was like much older he was in
his 30s at this point now it's about
1:00 a.m. so she sees him knocking on
the door and she's just like no you
can't come in it's one o'clock in the
morning what the [ __ ] are you doing here
and sends him away now he just makes
some kind of statement that something
horrible is gonna happen or some
horrible incident is gonna happen or
something like that
and then he disappears and then again
his his whereabouts are unaccounted for
for the next two hours also now the next
time they find him these two truck
drivers are driving down the Autobahn
that are the a45 and they see his
Volkswagen Golf like wrecked off the
side of the road so they stop you know
to call from the little emergency phone
or whatever right there by the road now
they see that gun the hunter is
completely naked and is sitting in the
passenger seat of his wrecked car now
he's still conscious so when the police
and the ambulance and stuff like that
get there he's like well there were four
other guys in the car with me but they
took off and these people like will they
friends of yours and he said no but they
didn't say he didn't say that they he
said something about them beating him up
right so they took they put him in the
ambulance and they tried to take him to
the hospital but he dies in the
ambulance now they find out later on
that the cause of death was not a car
accident he had actually been run over
by a vehicle other than his Volkswagen
Golf they also determined that he was
already naked when he was run over so at
this point so ok but what was the cause
of death
brain hemorrhage or getting run over by
a car yeah generally you know yeah being
all beat up from getting run over by a
car and like I said he was it and it
should be noted this is the end of
October in Germany so it was cold it was
very cold outside so here's that there
are so many mysteries why good there was
tripping to me that's and you know I'm
kind of leaning toward that now I don't
know like I said according to his wife
he had issues with paranoia he'd been
talking about people being after him
[ __ ] like that
so why he suddenly sat up and said I've
got it and then wrote these letters or
numbers on a piece of paper
now some people said maybe that's maybe
that's a car license plate number some
people have said that there's a Romanian
radio say
that has callsigns similar to that they
don't know what it has to do with the
case but they're like well there is one
that has that the letters tze are
actually a food additives that is put in
yogurt and he did work in that industry
it's like people are you know some
people are like maybe it's supposed to
be upside down and it's numbers you know
maybe the G is a six that boy is
tripping but yeah so they're not really
sure what happened so I was listening to
some other podcast about this and
somebody came up with a good thing so
like I said I don't know if he was
murdered if it was an accident and
people like trying to cover it up I
don't know I don't know if there really
were four people at his car it seemed
weird that he was in the passenger seat
I think what might have happened since
there was such a long time where he was
unaccounted for like people in the bar
did see him hit his head they said he
wasn't drunk at that point but you know
if he hit his head maybe he had a
concussion or something like that after
he left that bar they don't know where
he was for the two hours before he
turned up on that old lady's doorstep
she did not specify whether she thought
he was drunk or anything like that so he
might have gone to some other bar and
drank someplace else in addition to
having like a head injury maybe he ran
into some people he knew maybe you know
what I mean you drank you do dumb [ __ ]
maybe he said I'm gonna take off all my
clothes and run around in the middle of
the road I got an EZ and he got hit by a
car and then whoever hit him was like
[ __ ] let's like put him in his car and
make it look like an accident and then
they took off I got an easy explanation
okay let's hear it he had some kind of
brain aneurysm yeah blood vessel broke
in his brain and he's bleeding inside of
his brain and parts of his brain was in
the frontal area was getting starved of
blood flow he started at hallucinate and
could go crazy at home that's where he
came up Louis Yahtzee stuff goes into
the bar falls because he's losing
coordination and then you know driving
down the street taking his clothes off
thinking people are with him running out
in the street it gets hit by a car he's
acting strange people put him back into
his car they leave cuz I don't want to
be you know be responsible for running a
guy over and then he died that's what I
think that's kind of when I'm leaning on
of him he had some kind of a brain
hemorrhage
and had the house right I think it's
like people are and you know it this
it's kind of a weird case just because
of the whole Yangtze thing and they're
like you know and [ __ ] like that but
maybe that might not have had anything
to do with anything
no he's just Oh tripping because his
yeah brain was [ __ ] up he had some
kind of a blood vessel of some sort
broken his in his brain he was thirty
something right yeah I think so yeah
maybe yes there are head injury a few
days before that went untreated he
didn't know and then the you know the
the blood clot burst or you know and and
you know it's something like that like
that that would probably explain why
he'd been having all these like paranoid
delusions yes because I really don't
think yeah there's a lot of weird
details about this but I really don't
think that there's any kind of
conspiracy I don't think anyone was
trying to kill him out of injury yeah I
don't think it was anything like that I
think it was just a strange series of
circumstances that looks bizarre you
know in retrospect he had some kind of a
heavy bite he didn't know about it later
it got worse and then he went crazy yeah
it definitely does seem like he had some
kind of episode yes I think he took off
his own clothes I don't think anybody
knows I don't know like none of the
reports I said said if the if the
clothes were in the car or if they were
by the side of the road I've never
really seen any thing that said if they
ever found them I've had a head injury
before you know ya know cert serious
head injury your brain is bleeding
internally yeah and you don't really
know what the problem is you think
you're going insane and yeah of course
yeah it's our boys off you know people
people that uh you know under the
influence of weird drugs like Flocka and
[ __ ] take their clothes off and yeah I
feel like maybe he actually did maybe he
was drinking or and that was
exacerbating it to wit or blood clots
and so maybe he had been going from bar
to bar and was just getting drunker
drunk and it was like making it worse
and worse and then maybe he actually was
trying to drive somewhere he crashed his
own car and then got out to threw his
clothes off and then went into the road
looking for help maybe and got hit by
car and then somebody didn't see him and
hit him well you know when you and then
put him back in his car to make it look
like you know you know or he turn your
brain isn't working
right because you know you yeah you do
all kind of weird [ __ ] right yeah so I
kind of feel like that maybe what it is
I don't think that's and I don't know if
yog si has anything good you know
anything um II dreamt up yeah maybe it
was just some weird it's like oh I
thought of that's like just University
imagine you know I don't know you know
some you know I have heard that under
the effects of LSD yeah you know we've
heard might imagine things that are not
true
you know what I'm saying with head
injuries yeah you know I mean so it's
like that I do kind of feel like that's
why I mean it's heard this you know yeah
he probably was like I said I that would
actually I like the head injury thing
that it actually made me head injury
that maybe happened before that because
that we do three days before yeah that
would explain like why his wife said he
was acting paranoid and thinking people
were out to kill him and [ __ ] like that
it might have been that he didn't
realize he was suffering from a head
maybe not and there was a blood clot in
there that was manic it's like pushing
on him safe right but then the the clot
broke and then the bleeding started and
then it got worse yeah and then he goes
drinking that makes it even worse oh
yeah well he doesn't actually drink
though he falls off port but you know
they didn't see him drinking that bar
but like I said his motion his movements
like after he left that bar unaccounted
for for two hours and then after he left
that old woman's house and like I said
she didn't specify whether she thought
he was drunk or not she just tell him to
go wakes it was the middle of the night
and then his whereabouts and then he was
found injured two hours after that so
there's like four hour time gap in there
was digging and drinking I'm saying most
plausible he suffered a head injury a
few days before but it clawed it then a
few days later the clot broke yeah and
then on sudden Yahtzee
you know whatever starts acting crazy
taking his clothes off crashing his car
he gets hit by a car he dies yeah that's
what happened it's a I mean it's a
pretty it's like you know there's it's
frustrating cuz there's not a logical
there's not a huge amount of details on
it it's like most of the stuff about it
like the original Wikipedia
in German which I did not speak there
are some translations of it around but
you know there's a lot of details have
been left out so it's kind of doing well
based on what you told me I'm gonna say
it hey dangerous it does kind of sound
like that to me too I don't think there
was any like conspiracy there probably
weren't even four guys in the sound like
he had enough money for there to be a
conspiracy right you gotta be a rich
[ __ ] for a conspiracy to form
around you that's what I mean it jumps
on a bike he just sounds like yeah he
maybe had some paranoid he got hit in
the head a couple days before I think
now some people said I forgot to mention
this but actually the truck drivers
independently said that they did see
another person around the wrecked car a
guy like in a bright were in a white or
a brightly colored jacket mean anything
so I'm gonna stop and check on it right
he what was going on yeah and some
people saw a hitchhiker that night you
around the same area but yeah this that
person could have just been checking
like oh this guy's drunk and any leaves
yeah and actually I kind of think that's
probably what happened to if they if the
truckers did see this particular guy I
don't think he was necessarily in the
car have anything to do maybe he had
been hitchhiking it Samaritan and he
just kind of came to see and then he
said oh the truck drivers are here
though they'll you know help him it was
a probably a good Samaritan and then he
saw the guy to goes managed eats
hammered you got this car naked dudes
taking the car it is pretty sad though
if that is what happened to him cuz it
sounds like it wasn't really was it
really his fault he seemed to just kind
of have some crazy [ __ ] happened to him
that day it's not I'm gonna say that was
a head injury
yeah been there done that yeah yeah he
knows yeah
alright so um I'm gonna take a break
right now cuz we're a little over the
halfway point and when we come back cuz
I wanted to kind of spend the second
half of the show talking about the
Voynich manuscript and all the cool [ __ ]
about that I like this case yeah this is
always something that's like really
really fast Mannion to this manuscript
for a while yeah and I've been wanting
to do a show on this for a long time so
we're gonna talk about that on the
second half and right now we're gonna
take a little break so we'll be back in
just a couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day that this house and will
continue to be on somebody Ginny's got
some new shirt designs up four of them
really good ones to Atlanta Ripper who
put Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah
they're really good they're very high
quality shirts Jenny and I we're sure
our own shirts at certain times when
we're trying to put a spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description WWL
comm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out our
store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cotton
they look really cute JD's got some so
thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back on this code break-in
type show ya talking about the Voynich
manuscript very far they're very famous
I like this
I am so I've been fascinating this book
ever since I found out about it remember
how I first found out about it probably
on one of those likes Discovery Channel
shows when the Discovery Channel used to
be good yeah they did like a whole
documentary just on this one book yeah
they're actually about what this is yeah
there was one that came out a couple I
think he came out in 2014 maybe that
that I watched earlier today I can't run
what it's called I've the the clip from
the beginning of the videos it was taken
from the beginning of that but basically
so the Voynich manuscript to break it
down jetty break again it's named after
Wilfrid Voynich he was actually the guy
who he purchased it in 1912 from like
this monastery like this book collection
this monastery like in [ __ ] Italy or
something like that so why would she pay
for this thing
um I don't know how much he paid for it
at the time okay um I know how much
people paid for it a little bit later on
yeah but not hundreds of thousands
actually one guy that bought it later on
in the 20th century I believe he paid
24,000 25,000 he tried to sell it in the
60s for 160,000 but couldn't find a
buyer it's a beautiful handmade medieval
book yeah bunch of drawings in it a
bunch of writings nobody knows what the
shit's about and nobody knows what the
[ __ ] it says it's not in any known
language and yeah the weird thing about
it okay now for a long time before they
actually did cuz you know I'm not gonna
bury the lead or anything like that they
do how old this book is now because for
a long time before they did you know
carbon dating on the paper it's not
actually paper it's calfskin that the
pages are made of so before they did
carbon dating on that [ __ ] you know
people were saying everything from Oh
Raja modern homage your bacon wrote it
or maybe Voynich did it because he was
an antiquarian and he would have known
how to fake fake something like that but
now that they have done carbon dating on
the pages and they did several pages
they just sliced up little bits of the
sides they know with 95% certainty that
this book
came from between 1404 and 1438 which
means that most of the you know because
they don't know who wrote it either so
most of these speculations about who the
author was whether it was because even
at the time like back in the 1600s when
there are mentions of it people thought
oh maybe it was Roger Bacon maybe it was
john dee the you know alchemist or his
spirit guide at cali maybe it was
Leonardo da Vinci when he was a kid
yes so none of those can be true because
the book is actually older than that so
what was it 14 Oh what
14:04 214 38 was when this book was read
that means the new world had not even
really been discovered right so yeah so
the thing about it is that here it here
it is it's about 240 pages they don't
know exactly because some of the pages
fold out you know they have foldouts
like you know that come out this way
they they have some that fold out like
two big huge like a poster like a poster
type of thing so they're not sure
exactly when your pages because you
don't really know how to count them now
they do know that at some stage there
were probably more pages they said
probably originally it was about 270
pages because some of the pages are
missing and we're probably missing when
Voynich bought it in 1912 and they think
also that maybe the pages might have
been in a different order now from what
they can determine this appears to be
some kind of medical book or medical
encyclopedia of some type yeah because
it's divided into several sections the
largest section is what they call the
herbal section and it looks like some of
the botanical type books of the time of
the Middle Ages it has like these kind
of crude but very colorfully painted
illustrations of various plants and then
all this text next room that's
presumably explaining what you do with
them and stuff like that all the layers
that nobody knows what it says if some
of these drawings are weird when you
think about those drawings of like
plants but they're kind of mixed with
humanoids yeah and it's weird
because in some ways it looks very much
kind of like a early renaissance late
medieval drawing and kind of childlike
very it's a weird mixture when you see
it
Jenny's probably gonna slip in some
photographs in the videos yeah there's
tons of photographs yeah it's almost
kind of like a thing is online yeah it's
weird
it almost looks like a child drew it a
certain it kind of does yeah I can draw
I can draw pretty well what what they
used to draw with back then was very
difficult you couldn't really sketch you
know I mean it was they were very
limited so most people that made books
and most people that drew really didn't
know how to draw the art of drawing was
kind of lost in the Roman period really
they could draw I mean look at this
guy's look at their statues I mean they
they knew what Gestalt was how to make
something look real in this period they
they they didn't they didn't really have
a technique or the materials to do it
but it's still a very artistic book in
many ways I mean they're trying to draw
certain details but it's weird because
the context you're not really sure what
it is they're trying to tell you
especially with numerous most well the
weird thing about it too especially in
the herbal section is that pretty much
all of the plants that are Illustrated
um botanists cannot really identify like
they don't really look all that much
like existing plants right um some of
them they almost look like and on a
documentary I was watching about this
they had somebody that was speculating
they said well sometimes like these
botanicals and books of this type from
the same period sometimes you would get
plants drawn not in the realistic
fashion as as you would do in a later
encyclopedia like you know
post-enlightenment perhaps but it was
something like they would draw them in a
symbolic fashion trying to show through
illustration what you would do with this
particular plan yeah trying to reduce
the plant to like an emoji or an icon uh
yeah I suppose it's kind of
like that there's just like they it's
this is kind of what the plant looks
like but this is what it does so that's
what we're gonna make right you know
what I mean
so they were speculating that maybe
that's why they couldn't really identify
like one of them kind of looks like a
sunflower yeah but now we're not really
yeah some people have also said well
maybe there's some kind of an alchemical
meaning to this like the M yeah the
number of petals the colors of them what
the face is meant maybe some people
thought maybe they were a some kind of
like a symbolism used in alchemy yeah
but you know it's I don't think it to me
like I said the largest portion of the
book which I believe I believe it's 130
folios is the botanical section so it's
largely plants with just this
inscrutable text next to it which
presumably is describing what the plan
is there is also a section that is that
appears astrological it has like you
know big like Zodiac looking things with
obvious zodiac things it's like a little
go like yeah fishes and stuff like that
so it's you know but that was something
that had to do with medicine at the time
that was your astrological signs that
was that was quote-unquote science it
was in the 1400 they wouldn't have
thought that was strange at all
there is one section that they call
cosmological that looks like it might be
star charts or like something about the
planets and then one of the weirdest
things well and then they like at the
the very last section which is like
pretty short appears to be recipes
because it shows the plants but like
they're cut up in little pieces and like
like almost like it's telling you how to
make certain preparations one of the
weirdest things about the illustrations
is the little naked ladies yeah this
thing is full of little naked ladies yes
some of which are pregnant and they
always seem to be like in little tubs of
water a little bathtub a take it little
baths and all that like the bathtubs and
like the the water that they're in is
usually like attached by little like
tubes and like little systems of like
little tubes like irrigation canal yeah
I remember other ones that were kind of
weird like a bunch of people dancing
around things and then
going into water or you know I mean it's
not really sure what it is they're
trying to tell you yeah it's super weird
yeah or like plants slowly evolving step
by step into some woman or to some man
remember that remember that kind of yeah
you're like what are they trying to tell
us
plants turning into people you know yeah
she was like a Mandrake root yeah cuz
that wasn't that was something they used
in witchcraft along as the root of the
Mandrake plant looks like a person kind
of in the text person shaped the text is
totally intelligent unintelligible you
just you can't and I'm telling you like
everybody interprets okay like I said
before they carbon dated this [ __ ] to
the 1400s a lot of people there were oh
there was a large contingent of scholars
that thought that maybe this was a
forgery yeah or that maybe it wasn't
necessarily a forgery but it was
something that somebody like one of the
big theories that rolled around was that
John D and Edward Kelly who was his
spirit medium that they actually wrote
this book to sell to one of the to an
emperor that they work for I can't
remember which one it was but they but
it didn't mean anything it was just some
invented like angel language but they
wanted to make it look like all spooky
and alchemical and stuff so that the
emperor be like whoa I need to have that
[ __ ] here have all my money yeah in case
you guys didn't know there was a whole
industry even in the medieval era of
selling fake alchemy oh yeah nobles and
if they paid for it and to sell fake
books to Nobles yeah and a lot of this
stuff ended up in Christianity like for
instance there were whole books written
objective demonology of how many demons
and what their names were and they would
sell these books to noblemen yeah kings
saying the well this is what the church
knows about the demons totally
fabricated by some guy that's been kind
of handed down in Christian tradition
you know the gold look up a book of
demonology how the hell do you know what
demons are a nice thing about demonology
or alchemy or anything you pretty much
just pull stuff out of your eyes write
it down in a Bible they can write it all
fancy like oh yeah
and then be like lattes elizabeti bombs
and all that's not in the Bible those
dudes made that episode that [ __ ] the
gangstas biblical fanfiction yeah so for
a long time one of the theories going
around that the Voynich manuscript was
bad she and Kelly had put together
something like that like Eunice invented
like made-up language just to make it
look more mysterious and more alchemical
like we can't this isn't some like the
the language of the gods and yeah you
can't read it no mortal can read and
blah blah was that Mecca by the book
you'll figure it out eventually
yeah and [ __ ] like that but like I said
once they established that it was much
earlier because I mean John D and Edward
Kelly lived about a century and a half I
believe after this book was written so
it obviously couldn't have been them so
so the thing is now there's two schools
of thought is this text because it does
appear to me in something the
interesting thing about it there's about
twenty five distinct characters that
look as though they are letters but it's
no alphabet that anybody knows of
although some of the letters do kind of
look similar to some familiar letters
the patterns of the words appear to have
some type of meaning they're not random
and but nobody has been able to figure
out is this and and another weird thing
about it too is that there's no mistakes
nobody scratched anything out nobody
wrote over anything do you know if that
tells me though that it was a copy it
may have been that it's not the original
it may have been somebody might have
just been copying but it's weird that
nobody made several versions I mean this
is like a 270 page book and they wrote
it down and it's this very elegant
little figures I remember I remember
seeing documentaries on this and looking
at the pages that they were showing and
I remember thinking if this is a forgery
it's not a very good forgery like if I
was gonna make a fake alchemy book mine
would have looked a lot better yeah I
was thinking at the time that this is no
this is an actual real book this is a
book that you used to do something with
and I was thinking it's either alchemy
or medicine to me it looks like sure
that's supposed to work that it's not
supposed to fool you into working it's
something that's supposed to work it
just it looks too bare-bones you know
I'm talking about it looks too much like
a manual yeah that you know I mean
because a hoax manual I thought at the
time looking at it would have been a lot
more ornate and a lot more impressive
yeah you know what I mean to me it seems
like why I don't know why you would do
if you were gonna fake something yeah
why would you go to all the trouble I
mean okay like I said all of the pages
are calfskin which was not cheap back
then and some of the pieces of catskin
are very large I mean they're like four
letter sized pages it's like poster size
the pigments that were used we're not
particularly cheap either this book
would have cost a lot of money and even
though the book nowadays that you know
the one that's in it's actually been
donated to the Yale I think it's called
the by Nike library or something like
that yeah the by Nike rare book library
so it's in Yale now but the cover that
it has now is made of goat skin but they
think because of insect borings and
everything like that they think that it
had a wooden cover initially and that it
had like tanned leather on the inside
but that cover has been lost so that may
have had the author's name on it that
may have had the name of it on there but
if they don't know what happened to it
so it has a different cover now but the
way that it's if you were gonna fake it
why would you go to all this trouble to
get all this calf skin to get all of
this stuff why would you make up a
language yeah I mean if you wanted to
write it in code there were ways to do
that that were easier I mean you could
do a DaVinci and Ray machete mirror math
written in a code that could have been
broken it had been really impressive
when you read it and the pictures would
have been a lot more impressive and a
lot more mystical it would have had
demons and angels and weird geometrical
[ __ ] he asked me I was looking at it and
going no that's that's a real manual
about something that's really not all
that mysterious you just can't read it I
was thinking I was out
to me in medicine I think it's like a
women's health manual yeah you were you
were saying is I think that might be
what it is showed a lot of women taking
baths and green stuff and little
pregnant and little pregnant women yeah
and you know stuff like that I don't
know I I think there might be a couple
little naked man in the old me what
they're talking about is taking a bunch
of herbs and put it in hot water to make
tea and you bathing in it yeah
in certain it sits on certain pages so
you're dead medicine yeah they're
talking about medicine now some people
have said like I said yes it could be
planted little happy faces autumn and
[ __ ] was hilarious I mean yeah yes it
could be written in code um some people
have speculated that it could be a type
of code called I think it's called
steganography where some of the text is
gibberish but only it's like every
second letter means something cuz that's
kit was kind of a common thing up for
the time but pretty much everyone that
has gone through scuzz they've done like
computer AI on the stuff they're like it
does seem to make sense to make sense
like a real language like it doesn't
seem like it's just made up gibberish
shooters went through it and they see it
kept indicating that there were patterns
right and like that would see and that
means it's a it's an it's a language yes
they don't know what like it's just we
don't know what language it is
now some I saw some research that said
that the structure of the language
seemed almost more like an Asian
language like maybe some types of
Chinese or maybe Thai or something like
that from the period is sort of sort of
like Cyrillic or mostly yeah some of the
letters they don't really kind of look
like our sort our letters so some people
have maybe speculated that it's possible
that maybe somebody that didn't speaks a
Chinese or something like that used an
invented language to write stuff down
phonetically which was something that
people did at the time particularly if
they didn't really understand the
language they would just kind of write
it down as they heard it but since they
didn't have they didn't know how to do
a Chinese characters for example they
would just like make up like a little
alphabet hey bug okay well this yeah or
it's like okay this symbol means this
sound or this syllable or something like
that so that was something that went on
at the time so you would think that
let's say they're trying to write down
Chinese they would probably would have
written it phonetically in the language
of the author so if it's an Italian guy
he would have written down Chinese words
as they would have been written in the
Italian yeah that's what you it doesn't
seem to be that's what it is like I said
that was there there is precedent I
think that's close though based on what
we know there is precedent for making up
an alphabet to transcribe a language
that you don't speak or that you don't
understand that you're just trying to
write down phonetic so there is
precedent for that but then you so you
have to consider well who's the market
though right if they're sewn into China
it would be written in their own
language if they're so yeah to the
Italians they would have translated it
into Italian but they haven't done that
and the issues going on about this now
there's one little detail in here that
makes them think that whoever wrote it
was probably from the north of Italy or
was living there at the time because one
of the little drawings that's in there
is of a little castle yeah and the
little castle has a particular type of
crenellations which is called
Swallowtail yeah now they're like now in
the later Middle Ages that um you know
that sort of style of castle was kind of
spread throughout Europe but at the time
this book was written the only place
that those castles existed was northern
Italy and it's a very very specific
drawing with this very specific type
they're kind of it kind of looks like a
little curved yeah when you look at the
book and the drawings if you asked me it
looks it looks like early Renaissance
Italy mm-hmm it just looks like Italian
stuff so I'm kind of feeling that that
they were they were the center of art
and fashion and exactly it all makes
sense that it's Italian so I kind of do
feel like that that's probably where it
was written or where the person that
wrote it hailed from
so as I said you know pretty much every
language has been wet you know whether
it's a code whether it's gibberish
some people have said maybe it's ancient
Hebrew like you know some people have
said maybe it's um it's this one kind of
code where you have all these there was
this one guy he was a British dude and
he said what you could do is you could
just make this big grid with all of
these characters on it these little
imagines of 25 imaginary characters and
then you could make this little card
with little holes cut out and you just
put it down on there and just like
randomly it just has little suffixes and
prefixes and just put them together so
it looks like words but it's really not
he's like so that could be a possibility
that it actually is gibberish but it
looks like words because they've just
put together random prefixes and
suffixes however something that I saw
when I was researching this and this is
something that just came out this year I
don't new theory
oh yeah I don't even think that the
paper evidently the guys that have
figured this out like submitted a paper
about I don't know believe it's been
published to the audience to the
audience what she told me about this new
thing that came out this just rings true
to me this is probably what it is yeah
it's like they actually posted about a
12 13 minute YouTube video that's kind
of like just given a little thing of how
they figured it out and stuff they
haven't translated the whole manuscript
but I kind of feel like they may be on
the right track I'm like I said I'm not
a linguist so they could be totally off
or they might be like we can't check but
yes kind of like they were on the right
track so this guy he's actually an
electrical engineer but he he's
interested in old Turkic languages as a
hobby and he studied it for a really
long time so he said when he was looking
at the the Voynich manuscript he said
that he noticed that a lot of the
prefixes and suffixes of the words they
say he said that looks a lot like old
Turkic which is distinct from modern
Turkish although you
said that some of the words in there are
the same as modern yet and in Turkey and
then we jump in here during this during
this area era of the early 1400s Turkey
was also kicking ass in their in their
civilization so a person in early or
early Renaissance Italy would have been
interested in what science was doing in
Turkey so this sounds very plausible to
me yeah it really does seem like a form
of Turkish yeah he is speculating it's
it's this guy and his two sons and
they've been working on it for a while
and they said what we wanted to do they
started with some of the astrological
charts because they said we assumed that
the words were going to be like for
months or seasons or something like that
which they actually did determined that
they you know Syd said things like you
know autumn month or harvesting season
or arid season or whatever which kind of
seemed to line up and then they said
after we sort of got into it then we
decided that we were gonna take one page
and we were gonna try and translate the
whole thing like using the system and
see if it matched up with the
illustration so they picked this one
particular folio that had sort of a
sunflower II looking thing on it and
they evidently translated it according
to the video and it was talking about a
sunflower and like how like different
parts of it you could use and how you
would take it and all this other kind of
stuff and what it would do to fix you
and blah blah blah so if this is correct
it's not um he's like it's not a literal
transliteration of turkic he's like what
it is it's almost some of the words are
the same and he's like in a couple of
the words and sounds are even kind of
the same as the modern Turkish words but
he's like it appears as though someone
took the stuff in Turkic and then tried
to write it phonetically with a with a
half invented alphabet so like I said
it's sort of like what we were saying
before like somebody trying to
transliterate Chinese like using an
invented alphabet for the purpose
because you know I mean but this is
partial so it's
almost like there's some characters that
are kind of the same but some characters
that are invented but they're trying to
figure out like which characters you
know map onto which letters you write
but it does sorry so here's an analogy
during this same era and even up to - up
until today people that were into
medicine would practice medicine in
Greek they don't speak Greek that's not
in their Berlin that's not in their
normal language yeah but they would
actually all their medicinal stuff is in
Greek well if you're gonna get knowledge
from Turkey
you're gonna start practicing medicine
in Turkic yeah all right but you don't
use the the alphabet you're using your
own alphabet or a modified version of
your alphabet to express Turkish that's
what they're talking about yeah yeah I
mean that is the gist I'm getting
rightness and that might make a
difference back in those days because
this is all being kind of mixed in with
alchemy and astrology maybe they thought
it was important to practice Turkish
medicine in Turkish yeah you know I'm
talking about you're saying certain
things while you're doing certain like
it's a spell yeah so you have to say it
in it's um something approximating
Turkic wouldn't you say that's what
they're talking about I think that might
be it it's and like you said
historically that does really seem to
line up because if indeed the person
that wrote this is from northern Italy
as they think it is because of the
little castle drawings and if indeed
this is actually a modified form of old
Turkic written quasi phonetically right
someone that didn't really speak the
language then that would actually
explain a like it kind of fits together
like I said yeah this is pretty recent
they only put the the video up earlier
this year and it was just kind of a
summary of what they were doing and they
kind of showed this one page that they
translated like I said it's this guy in
Turkey and his two sons that just kind
of we're doing it as a hobby and you
know they thought they figured it out so
they're gonna try and do the whole book
they've said
to paper and everything like that like I
said they could be completely full of
[ __ ] I don't know I just found it while
I was looking for you know was well I
was looking for [ __ ] about this and it's
not even like I said it's not even on
the Wikipedia page like the Wikipedia
page hasn't been updated with this
information so I'm not sure how legit it
is but it sounded checks out possible it
sounded plausible think about it you got
two Italian doctors practicing Greek
medicine they start stunting towards
each other
discussing Greek medicine in Greek yeah
I mean yeah I mean that's kind of like
because you know there isn't a big
difference between science and magic
during that time so yeah ritual involved
yeah so you got two Greek doctors
Italian Greek doctors talking about
medicine and Greek almost kind of like
they're talking and discussing spells
and [ __ ] well if they're bringing in a
Turkish discipline maybe they were doing
the same thing in Turkish yeah but they
didn't really know that but no the Alpha
didn't know the Alpha but they kind of
knew the language or they had an Italian
version of that alphabet that helped
them speak that language while they
practice Turkish medicine that would be
a trippy that that kind of checks out
that's like something the medieval 's
and the early Renaissance people would
do because they they did things based
upon ritual there was a magical element
to the [ __ ] that they did back then
because they did [ __ ] not really know
why they were doing it was just because
Galen said to do it it was that too much
too much [ __ ] that yeah this is a
problem Galen didn't rope too much [ __ ]
he just couldn't shut up man could he
stop right kept like [ __ ] there was
one could want one one student of Galen
this is a more of a modern study in all
games writing said that actually Galen
held science back in medicine back
because you wrote too much and everybody
took everything that he wrote as gospel
even though he's wrong about a lot of
[ __ ] so he actually held the progress of
medicine that's the danger of the
argument from Authority
exactly
well he wrote all these tomes so he must
be correct yeah and I think I feel like
there was a lot of that during that time
period to where it's like you know it's
the knowledge of the Ancients it must be
corrected right and what you still see
that like in a lot of kind of New Age
you're like paranormal circles nowadays
you know something came from like some
society 2,000 years google it must be
right right because they had some kind
of special non like now they're probably
just done yeah but where I could have
some Italian guys practicing Turkish
medicine and they're making tea baths
and putting pregnant women in the tea
bath bath prego and it according to the
manual they have to say certain things
in Turkish right while they're doing it
because magic and medicine and astrology
and alchemy were all basically the same
thing back then which you can really
tell from this book because like I said
it's it's Plantin that it's all
astrology yeah and then it's all like
planets and [ __ ] right and then they got
like little recipes and I mean like when
the moon is full you got to do this that
the other thing and they're showing
these women getting into these baths and
coming out in evolution and a progress
but progression in these drawings so
that tells me that there's there was
ritual involved yeah it doesn't seem
like that so they had to say certain
things
yeah the way she's manager you'd mess up
the spell basically yeah but like I said
if these dudes are correct it would kind
of explain all I think they're onto
something it would explain like it like
I'll have to show you like I just
explained it to him the Italians were
seeing this as in it as a foreign
advanced exotic spiritual technology
involving all the major sciences
astrology medicine you know I mean with
the herbs and crap you know saying
certain things and alchemy and magic
altogether that's gotta be what it was
it does make just based on mr. Rawlings
that's what I'm seeing because see I
never bought that doubt that it was just
gibberish or that someone would fake it
cuz why the [ __ ] would you go like I
said why would you go to all that
trouble like I know people Forge things
but it seems like more trouble than it's
worth to forge something like that well
I think that looked like it took a long
or jury would have been more mysterious
and more extravagant I think yeah it
looked too much like something that was
supposed to function yeah it's been like
it's workman like right I mean it's
nicely done right um you know the
pigments are still very bright but
whatever they're showin evidently worked
yeah or they thought it worked but yeah
it looked more like a practical tone
yeah then one that was supposed to be
serious or something for you and to beat
you to buy the book that's right or
something that was supposed to be like
you know decorative ear oh it looked
kind of practical yeah it wasn't over
complicated and like I said I think that
I think the explanation for the plants
not really looking like any plants that
they know of is just kind of them either
the guy was not very good at drawing the
network or they'd never seen them maybe
he was talking about plans for another
part of the world they'd never seen he
just heard them described or like I said
maybe they were drawing them like in a
symbolic fashion like kind of you know
leaning more toward what they did if and
why didn't actually look like might have
been so simple as it says right there
sunflower
everybody knows what a sunflower is the
drawing didn't have to be accurate yeah
kind of a whatever you know pit road
whatever something yeah okay it says
right here the Mandrake root and you
know everybody knows what that is you
can go to the bark and buy it drugs so
the accuracy the drawing wasn't
important maybe to the readers yeah they
would know they would know exactly what
it looked like so yeah I gotcha
you weren't using the book to find and
identify the plant right you should have
or even should already know what it
looked like because it did seem like and
most of the people that owned it over
the years like I said it was donated to
Yale in 1969 but most of the people that
owned it over the years from you know
like little names that they found
written in there were also medical
doctors or alchemists or things like
yeah so you know I I kind of feel like
that's probably what it was it was is a
medical text probably women like you
said yeah and since most of the little
naked people in there are little ladies
yeah then I'm I don't know if there's a
little naked man in there or not I there
might be a couple but I think it's
almost all little ladies yeah so
basically times you don't
like a prototype gynecology manual yeah
probably someone well they were getting
into baths yeah I had something to do
with making sure that your baby with
help was healthy yeah maybe it was like
a midwives so good Davis it was yes
maybe it was for midwives
well it seems too expansive just to be
about probably more like a doctor that
was hired to come in and treat some
noble woman to make sure that the that
the child was a masculine child a
surprise some [ __ ] like that
if you put her in this mixture the baby
will be born a boy let's try that and if
it's a girl they're gonna like God
useless was the thinking of the time oh
I know nobody well there had to be an
heir to the throne you know it's not
like girls good anything we can't run
anything our lady brains are so soft and
pliable but yeah seriously I'll put a
link to to this guy's little YouTube
video and see what you think it's like I
said it seems kind of new but it sounds
kind of plausible and if they could
[ __ ] if they could translate that
whole book wouldn't that be [ __ ] well
it kind of lines up with the thinking of
the time right he asked me that probably
what it was that's what I mean like I
said it could be totally wrong I don't
know but it does sound kind of plausible
like it sounds more plausible than most
of the others yeah I heard about what
that what that thing says but yeah so um
I guess we will wrap it wrap this up
it's been kind of belong show but that's
okay you guys seem to like that so let's
see what what do I usually say at the
end Oh as I say every week remember if
you like the show to like share
subscribe and all your social media and
share with all your friends if you'd
like to financially support the show you
can go to patreon.com/scishow and give a
monthly donation or if you'd like to
give a one-time donation you can do that
too you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account also be sure to check out
our last movie review which was
Creepshow be sure to check out Tom's
shitty movies Facebook group where he
talks about various action movies
everybody talks about varying name yeah
varying degrees
shittiness yes these also i've gotten
some really really good stories and true
ghost stories and fictional stories for
our Halloween episode so if you would
like to submit and keep them rolling
then keep them coming in cuz we've got
like you know I think I got like three
or four or five really good ones so
that'll be cool it's gonna be a really
fun show hopefully so I'll put my email
in the counter you can email me at grave
cake at gmail.com just send me your
stories if you want them bread on the
Halloween episode and remember to go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and there we
have some cool shirts and tote bag that
you can purchase if you would like to do
so also go and subscribe to our channel
on bit chewed and Bo and dailymotion and
blah blah and all the other places that
we are and I think that will do it for
episode 110 we will see you next time
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]